let's see okay so we know
we can have the more general situation
with directions on edges
and for directly graph as you see that
quite different from directory ones
the matrix involved is not symmetric
eigenvalues are not real
so for undirected case we have tools
from spectrograph theory
random works if you look at those books
mostly are on reversible markov chains
and you have eigenvalues to find the
rate of convergence for random works
and we have trigger inequality
which
controls these partitions and local
partitions
it's sort of
main tool to analyze these
and we don't have any of that
for direct graphs
since i wrote a book on spectrograph
theory the most
inquiries i got is to ask about the
directed case so in the last few years i
was looking at the directed case
and
and you can see that for
the trigger inequalities well undirected
graphs has all sorts of applications
because of the cuts
partitioning and so on
um but most real-world graphs are
directed this is the uh bgp
routing graph or a gate protocol routing
graphs
when you write one message to another of
course it's uh directed
and
this is for from another student the
instant ex student instant messaging
network
also directed it because you send one
message from
a to b
so
uh what about trigger
inequality for directly graph but before
we get to that we have to uh get through
a few hurdles right so what do i mean
eigenvalues there what i mean laplacian
there
uh what do i mean trigger constant there
and what do i mean
uh what what are their relation
to random walks so so
there's
quite a bit to do
we can define uh
directly graphs the transition
probability matrix if we take this to be
typical ones
or you like
the weighted version
um
so for such a random walk
there's these typical questions right if
your random work will converge or not
if it converge what's the stationary
distribution and how fast you get there
and if you have some quantity
like eigenvalues to be able to control
how fast you converge
so these are really sort of
mathematically
sort of histories can you hear the shape
of a drum you want to say how fast and
slow things are converging but but now
we have these directed drums okay
all the edges have
and instead of using eigenvalues here we
need some quantities right
okay so here is the outline of the graph
we're going to define the laplacian
there
and
get the tigers inequality proof there
and have discrepancy in quality proof
there which is different from triggering
quality so stronger version
and then um
well graphs
usually we have
it
have tools if the graph is very nice
with great deal of symmetry then you can
use group representation i think in
earlier talks today that we heard some
from percy's talk
but in fact for the radiographs a
semi-group methods coming in if we get
to that and then there are problems
right
but
i couldn't help because i spent some
time here
um in the last two months
surrounded by a lot of people with new
results uh
on chica in qualities higher order tiger
inequalities
so
i was trying to read those papers and
try to
update my book right
and some of these proofs are pretty
difficult to read
in fact i'll do a survey those are very
nice higher trigger inequalities so
people here all know about hair
triggering qualities can i see a show at
hand
yes okay
how many people really read those papers
and understand the proof of those couple
papers
the authors definitely did
they're not easy to read
my students have a reading group try to
help each other and they're not easy to
read anyway i'm going to give you short
proofs
very ambitious here
if you haven't
if you have read that paper then you
really appreciate your proofs if you
haven't read then you really really
appreciate the show
okay so before i do the show proof i
have to say what the matrix we are
talking about right if and if it can be
used to capture the properties of the
grass
and we are going to use normalized
laplacian
i think uh here people use normalized
laplacian so often i was really very
happy
because when i first write my book on
using i realize normalized laplacian is
good capture sub graphs and so on but
for many years most people in
commentaries
love the
eigenvalues for adjacency matrix things
that i don't know like laplacian but now
it's really been used quite a bit more
okay
so
one reason for using it is that it's
sort of a symmetrized version
um
really one minus the eigenvalue of the
transition probability matrix
but it's symmetrized so we don't have to
worry about left eigenvalue right
eigenvalue and right eigenvector and so
on so so
and
and in particular the spectral gap
lambda 1 is the first non-trivial
eigenvalue
that's the
this one gap here
which gives a great deal of information
uh he gives the
topological information about
connectivity
but also for undirected graph one thing
i want to point out it has very nice
lower bound
one over the diameter times the volume
if you have simple graphs this is like
n cube a lower bar one over n cubed
lower
so your random work really
the i rate of convergence it's all
polynomial
it's nicely in a polynomial length okay
what is the story for okay
so one
one thing that's useful about
eigenvalues is that we can control the
diameter actually
so if you think about diameter which is
how many halves you need to
reach one vertex from another right
and the diameter is the longest
distance
and
you can use eigenvalue bound to
you you can use eigenvalue to bound the
diameter okay
and what we want to do is to carry
orders to the directed case
there's for
there's also this general notion of
isoparametric
so it's really coming from you know you
want to use a short curve to enclose a
unit areas in the plane then we all know
you should have a circle right but in a
graph then
we have
the situation you want to bound the
number of edges leaving
versus what
one way to
do it is
define the volume of a subset to be the
sum of the degree versus
finality
and we are going to use this version
uh
which is
particularly suited
using normalized laplacian but also for
general graphs we have big degree and
small degrees and
the eigen value here you see the the top
and bottom both are counting edges
versus here
count different things
okay the cheek ratio for subset here
we'll just
have a definition here
and trigger constraint of a graph
is
you have a subset and you have its
complement you pick
a big one
which is the same as you
which is the case because they share the
same boundary which is the smaller part
that's hs
i use this notion this notation so we
can go up to higher once easier
and this trigger constant
in some community called conductance
we have to
you know the first person used this
definition certainly didn't quite
realize
that laplacian has a lot to do with
electrical networks which conductance
has a different definition
so
fortunately this lecture we don't do
electrical networks
so
so okay as a trigger inequality says
that
the eigenvalue is sandwiched by
the trigger constant and it's square
i think now they
in some people they like like to write
this version
but it
depends on what you care about i can
vary more or
trigger constant more okay sort of
cleaner this way
okay higher trigger constant i'm also
going to define it
so you have
disjoint
k subsets
and you take the max
minimax
and in the case of
h1 then that's the same thing
okay
so there's recently this we're really
happy to see
very nice work about higher order cheek
accounts
or it's very often you see like this
better on the right it's k-square
i know
that's called cheating hiding the powers
okay let's honestly writing it this way
okay
um
so so so so
what i want first to do are these your
proofs right so let's do very short
proof for the trigger in quality
this will be in my updated book
okay but before i do that i need to do
characterization of trigger
so one way to do the trigger constant is
that instead of this
instead of dirichlet sum
which are two norms here we have one
node
this is just the absolute value
sum over all edges
the difference of the
function point okay
it is in my book actually
cheerful too
and and you
this uh you take the c you shift around
linear replacement
pick the best one
so this is a characterization of trigger
constant and it's equality it's equal
the first remark the supreme for the c
really should just take take it uh
on the medium
which means the value that have
the volume on the left have volume on
the right almost
the second remark is that this really
gives a rhythmic
bang upper bound so this is inc right if
you any pick any f you get upper bound
if you just pick this
this medium in the middle okay
and
because
what happened is that for f it
you give one
one
linear arrangement of all the vertices
and these edges stretch around
and you look at the smallest cut
the minimum
okay
here
you look at the number of edges going
across
you look at the trigger ratio over there
so so i have a typo here
really you look at all the subsets on
one side you for all those subsets you
look at the best uh trigger ratio that's
the alpha f okay so it's really an
algorithmic bound if you can find a good
f so
while we are talking about trigger in
quality one nice thing is that it's
actually a rhythmic proof because the
best cut gives you
uh
gives you that lower bank which means it
gives you that performance guarantee you
find a cut with that kind of guarantee
okay so here's a very short proof for
triggering quality so this the top line
is just from the definition right
and i here you can have the medium
then i do one rung of
this is nothing right
it's the definition i multiply the same
thing on top and bottom and crossy
schwartz then i'm done
much neater than
at least the proof i have in my
book which will be in the new revised
version when i'm sitting down to do
everyday
so let's
have a couple lines right
if you
accept my
cheeky
trigger
a constant
characterization
now i want to do higher order
trigger inequality i need two things
the first thing is
a weaker characterization of trigger
constant
and the second thing is the partition
into expander okay
so instead of this trigger
characterization i am favoring those
those f
which
f x d x sum up to zero
in that case i give up a factor of two
but still it's pretty good
so instead of the medium
i'm choosing
this one which is
from the linear algebra since more
favorable
okay
so i i'm going to use this weaker
characterization by giving up a small
constant too
and then guess what i also need this
partitioning to expanders
which is a very nice result
of
luca and
china
so basically
what it says that is that basically
for any k
okay you can find smaller k that which
has a big
big gap
okay
and in that case you can partition into
l parts
each part the inside
trigger constant this is not exactly the
trigger constant for the induced sub
graph see because the induced subgraph
volume is a little different in the
induced subgraph i'm sticking with the
old volume okay this ratio
is big
so it's not
trigger ratio for the induced subgraph
in the paper chord it's not exactly
right but it's not too far off okay
because i'm using the old volume in the
whole graph
it's almost like it's also h h star it's
not h
so i'm going to use this
i'm a little bit cheating right
i'm assuming these two things the greek
characterization and the partitioning to
expanders
and but i have to say that the proofs
for partitioning to expand that paper is
much easier to read than the previous
two higher trigger
in quality paper at least for me maybe
someone will argue with me no
okay so this is a show proof of higher
order triggering quality
so here i'm going to
this is
i can write it as a soup in this is this
is just the
definition right one of the definitions
so i'm going to choose these uh
i'm going to uh
what what do i do oh this is this is
nothing i'm just going to write it into
this form
obviously
oh it's d minus a right
okay right now i'm going to choose my
fees so this is soup so i'm getting
equality to be characteristic function
with these
these subsets
which means i am using that
partition into expander result okay
and here
if i i'm just going to choose choose
them to be like
just the restriction so this whole top
is the digitally sound you can write it
like this
and the bottom because it's disjoint
basis so i have this in chord
then on each
piece i just do do my argument like my
previous slide
then everything falling out
then all i have to do is to add lambda k
and
less than k here then i'm done
that's the proof
so
i am
slightly cheating in the sense i'm using
this partition into expanded result but
that's a very nice result
but with that i can get
triggering quality on one page pirate
shipping water
any questions
see you all there
nope okay
yeah yes richard but this could also
give alternate proof of the just just
for the k equals two case so you have
two expanders
does the proof look this so i notice
that you don't have a step of koshy
schwartz happening here
so what's sort of in two in the two
expander case are you saying that
i just plug in test vectors and that
lower bounds medium
that just using um
for for the case of two parts
we are using bigger tools than it's
needed because
look at this constant c
you suffer there
right but where are you getting around
the confusion what's that that's what
i'm trying
because it was still here
okay
because here from here to here i'm using
the
the quasi shorts i'm using using the
same argument as the previous page which
has a course in short
maybe there's experiments
oh yeah
uh yeah
i think it is okay this part to this
part i get a square okay
near qed oh oh i lost something
sorry
okay i lost i i forgot this that's a
typo
just did it today
okay so so now we can uh go back to the
direct graphs
getting
these triggers in quality for and
directly case away
okay
so uh
for directed graph
i'm going to use the transition
probability matrix
okay
so there's a prong for venus right
so it says so basically
when you look at the adjacency matrix
well
for the wrecking graph just a general
matrix
and
if you want to use peroneum for venous
then
if you get a unique
left eigenvector
if
the graph is irreducible which really
translated to strongly connected
so
neither suppose we assume the
irreducibility so once you have that
let's look at
what the stationary distribution mean v
p equals v right
so it's a left eigenvector
versus one is the right eigenvector
um so
the first thing about under about the
recti graph the big difference from the
undirected ones is this
grown vector the stationary distribution
if we have one
just by some example very easily
constructed you can see that
the
the the
distribution of feet can be vastly off
see for undirected case it's
proportional to degree
so the biggest one and the smallest
coordinate
is only off by a factor of n at most
right it's only binomially off but guess
what
in this graph
the stationary distribution you know
exponentially off
so which means
the smallest part is exponentially small
possibly
so you might say okay this
this
construction has a one very big
in-degree and small-out degree so it's
so lopsided no wonder
the stationary distribution is so
exponentially lopsided
okay i will construct this graph so the
in degree and our degree or very
friendly right
the in degree and our degree
only off by a small factor bounded
boundary degree bounded ratio okay
and guess what this graph is just also
exponentially
lopsided
or for its stationary distribution
yeah so that's a very big difference in
fact it could be as bad as n minus one
factorial for simple graphs
which means for the edge edge weight is
one okay
so
that's a very big difference this is the
stationary distribution for for direct
case is very unfriendly okay
it's not in the polynomial land
in the worst case of course
if we want to talk about convergence
then we also need this
property of a periodicity
we need
another
if if if it's
has a
like a cycle then it's going to
oscillate your
pebble it's not going to converge to
stationary distribution
but with these two conditions two
they turn out to be
necessarily insufficient
to imply convergence and
then you have your stationary unique
stationary distribution
so
we are going to assume from now on in
the rest of the lecture our graph is
strongly connected
and
end with this condition it's acyclic
so so
which usually which is a less serious
condition
irreducibility this connectivity is
essential but a periodicity very often
you can do lazy walks to get away from
it so
but anyway let's assume our graph has a
unique
stationary distribution
okay
then we are looking at our cuts right
we have a subset
s
and we are looking at the out boundary
which are the edges leaving our area as
okay
with arrows pointing out
so
we are going
this is just a definition a circulation
means
this f is
is a function assigning
values to my directed edge
and if
i lost a few view graphs
it is a circulation if for each point
the
uh incoming vertices you sum up
its f value is the same as outgoing
edges you sum up the f value
and it's a circulation
if it is a circulation then i can talk
about the subset
the f value on a subset of edges then
you just summing up
its value
on the on the
um
on the edges
and if it's a circulation then
if you
have a subset and it's complement then
the boundary
in either direction is the same
if it is a circulation
so i apologize i missed one new graph
which is the definition of circulation
but if you okay so if you accept this
this
okay
so i am going to define the circulation
with respect to v
if you have a stationary distribution
i'm going to use it to define a
circulation then i can define the cheek
relation
so i actually have a few examples right
so for some graphs the tiger ratio is
quite friendly
have a lower bound
okay
but for some graphs
now here i want to
define the
rayleigh quotient
already quotient
is this one
remember
um
usually we are taking
okay so where do i define the laplacian
i'm going to use my
stationary distribution this feed to
define
to define
uh
i'm going to so so so this fee is really
play the role of
b in the old days right
then off by a scale
sort of
giving my perfect definition right
trying to find my definitions
okay okay so let's let's try to forget
about this i i
just look at this one okay
so
remember for
undirected graph so this is really
generalization for the directed case
if your theoretical graph for every edge
you take one in both directions we
should uncover our undirected case so
look at this so this guy here
really played the role like for
underrated case is it is the uh
dam uh that um
so so this is d inverse a right so this
is like
canceling out okay
so so basically it is this one that's
the laplacian
if i uh
normalize it a little bit
okay
i'm just cramping too much definition
okay so basically i'm using these
the fee here this prong vector to modify
my
um
transition probability matrix
and this one is its transpose
so you can see
this laplacian after it's defined it is
uh symmetric
isn't that what we call the additive
symmetrization in my papers from the
1990s with sell of cost
it is possible but i think
a lot of that
previous definition very often just take
pp transpose
because mostly deal with transpose in
the in the l2 norm right right
by
the stationary distribution and so it's
the right subjective reversalization in
many papers
it's only deal with direct at a regular
graph right okay
okay
for regular graphs in fact i think
um
for regular graph it's just pp transpose
on the top but you have to divide it by
the
scale it up
in fact i i think
uh ins
with this definition then we can get our
rayleigh
quotient
which is
sort of coming back in the form very
similar to
what we see in the undirected graph
and
my
main point is that using this definition
i'm pretty sure traced back to percy's
paper and even in some of precise paper
have similar form
but the point is that the eigenvalue
there
we can get trigger inequality
and
one good thing about this
eigenvalues is that we can also use it
to uh this is a useful lemma so
basically this this this eigenvalue if
it is num
uh non-zero
if there is a gap here
then
we we will be able to bank
this
the singular value of this normalized
form
and the consequence of that is that we
can
find the total variation distance
here so basically you can get
total variation distance
this
back to the underrated case it's the
inverse of lambda
at the rate of the c
but this term shows up
the log of
this minimum degree this
which could be pretty exponentially
small right but it is behind this log so
it's not too bad
okay and you can use this to get the
diameter bound also
i'm not going to do the proof i only
want to say for
underrated diameter eigenvalue
inequality is like this
for k k regular graphs
for general graphs
your lambda you know
doesn't show up
i mean for
for regular
graph
you get a eigenvalue bound there so it's
of the spot
for four for expanded graph of the
greedy but for the directed case
there is off by a factor
which i would love to get rid of you
might say you know for
you probably
you might say you don't quite care about
the spectre
but
if you see from the different point of
view
for the extremal problem in
combinatorics if you fix the diameter
you argue about how the extremal graph
how big the graph can be
then you'll blow up exponentially
so
actually
interesting to deal with that constant
i don't know how much time i have
for um minutes okay in that case it's
not so bad we can still go on a little
bit
so uh
for usual underrated graph
very often when we are talking about
expanders they are really
have many implications many people might
think it means neighborhood expansion
rapid mixing
okay
but really if
lambda one has a gap here
then
from trigger inequality you get
neighborhood expansion and rapid mixing
of the lazy walks
on the other hand
if your lambda one is close to one
that is a much stronger
situation very different from this part
one
um
people talk about expanders so it's
is that this properties or is that this
properties
it depends on different papers using
different definitions
but the fact is that
if the lambda one is very close to one
then um
for this family for photographs with
this property is really quasi random
so
one way to say it is that see if you
care about controlling
the edges leaving a graph
to its complement
okay that's trigger inequality in place
right
in the other direction
you take any two subsets and you want to
bound the number of edges in between
see that is just a smooth special case
right
this in order to control this
if you use as a
discrepancy in quality in order to
control the discrepancy
you need
the eigenvalues lambda one close to one
okay it's a much stronger
notion it is so-called quasi-random it
is equivalent to a bunch of other
properties
large equivalent
equivalence class
of graph properties that each one
implies another almost like
you know in
studio computer science you talk about
equivalence
of computational complexity you know mp
complete and so on and so forth but for
these uh random like properties for
actually any graph properties you like
to find its right character a
classification
and
these are the quasi-random properties
so the the one
usually try to do at the beginning is to
bound the number of edges in between by
h density
times x and y
think i mentioned this before but for
those who haven't heard
that
see
this inequality is only good if
all one
vector is a good approximation to your
eigen
your principal eigenvector
and
in that case you can get a approximation
in a general case
if the graph is not almost regular
these are not no longer the projection
to your main eigenvector
then
really the right approximation is this
normalized form the volume is coming in
and for that we can also okay let's skip
okay
so the discrepancy
inequalities for directed graphs
we can also use eigenvalues there to
control the discrepancy inequality
but all the edge weight
is
modified
by
is defined by using the problem vector
if we do that
then you can control
the flow in between x
between x and y
so we also have a set of discrepancy
inequality for the direct case
of course
as you can see it all depends on the
prong vector quite a bit
um
so this is the
franklin is here
see in his thesis dealing with such
discrepancy in quality for directed
graphs
so um
i'm not going to
i'm not going to have time to talk about
the semi semi group spectral message too
much
i just want to end by
mentioning some of my favorite
problems on direct graphs
there is one
in fact there are many many
problems very simply stated for digraph
that we don't know
versus
in
ingress so here is another one
tons of curious commentarial problems
oh we want to determine that we want to
get the right order of f of
find a long increasing path
with the edge
okay i think i'm going to stop here
questions
for the last last one what is the
question
gb the question is to close this gap
i think i'm missing one the conjecture